the
[Music]
[Applause]
SE uh Hall of Famer Troy Aikman ESPN
Monday night football analyst joining us
on behalf of his beer brand eight and uh
eight is committed to producing first
class products no hidden agendas
authenticity matters come join the team
teammate T-Roy Aikman's number when he
played when you go to a cookout
do you expect somebody to bring a
football out therefore you feel
obligated to throw the football
yeah you know and verbally that happens
I find it more when I'm on vacation and
I'm on the beach uh you know it's an
interesting uh thing when you observe it
that it doesn't matter what age you
certainly see kids but you see adults
too the enjoyment that they get from
throwing a football
and the pressure Dan for me comes that
uh I I've thrown the ball maybe three or
four times since I retired and it it
it's not real pretty when I do throw it
right now at my age and uh the pressure
that I face uh to to look like I just
left the field I mean sometimes I just
try to avoid anyone who's throwing a
football out on a beach okay how far do
you think you could throw it right now
well not very far it's interesting
because just recently someone wanted me
to throw it uh I I don't know what's
going on I've got I've got some ailments
and uh my shoulder's been been giving me
some issues so uh maybe 30 yards right
now I'm not real sure I've never tested
it because I don't want to injure it
anymore
what's the one throw that still bothers
you
uh
uh well I don't know but that's a good
question I've never been asked that one
Dan that's why I enjoy doing your show
but
my biggest uh my biggest disappointment
athletically is not having beaten USC uh
while I was at UCLA those two years that
I started because both those games were
for the Rose Bowl
and as fun and as good as I think my
career was at UCLA
uh I think that like NFL quarterbacks
the standard is winning a Super Bowl for
UCLA this the standard really was
leading your team to a Rose Bowl and I
failed to do that but as far as throws
the one that maybe I look at right now
would be the 1994 NFC Championship game
uh against San Francisco
uh we had a we had a throat of Michael
Irvin that if we get the call you know
Dion Sanders was playing for the 49ers
defensive player of the year you know
that was one that had we have been able
to connect on that maybe we make the
comeback and we're able to come back and
win that game but did Dion take away
like half of the field
when you were facing him
uh for us he did not because he would
always match up with Michael Irvin and
which was which was a great contest
between those two guys I mean obviously
both Hall of Fame players uh our worry
was that at some point maybe Dion would
go to our number two receiver and then
they'd roll to Michael roll coverage and
I always thought that was the play for
them but they never did it so Dion he
wouldn't hear of that because he wants
to face the best receiver but we thought
that Michael was going to win his share
of battles and Dion was going to win his
and that ultimately is the way it
happened but I've said it many times and
and others have as well Dion without
question is the best defensive back that
I ever played against
Michael had 12 catches in that game
almost 200 yards yeah
but does sometimes it gets into a
one-on-one battle so Mike wants to win
his battle obviously wants to win the
game but sometimes it becomes too
personal and then you have to be you
know judge and jury and say Mike we have
to win a football I mean did that happen
with Michael with that big personality
oh yeah he uh you know there would there
would be you know he'd draw coverage of
course and he would get two sometimes
heck there'd be three guys on him and
we'd come over the sidelines and
and you know my my the guys called me
Roy and he'd say Roy you know you got to
just just throw it up there you got to
give me a chance and I said Michael I'm
not throwing it into triple coverage
it's just not going to happen and you
know but him you know him like all of
them uh it's no different today the
great ones you know they always feel
like they have a chance and that's what
that's what makes them great how would
you describe Jerry Rice to somebody who
never saw him
oh man he was like uh I you know I
equated a little bit to like Joe Montana
and Dan Marino you know I always thought
until Brady went on to do what he's done
I always thought Joe Montana was the
greatest quarterback of all time and but
Dan Marino was the guy who I enjoyed
watching play the most and and and Joe
kind of he just had this fluid ease of
everything just seemed easy for him you
know his drop back the way he threw the
ball whereas Dan everything looked like
a struggle you know the drop back the
throw and I would and I would probably
say the same thing with Jerry uh it just
was so fluid so easy uh at least the way
he made it look uh it was poetry
watching him run routes and I had a
chance to watch him up close of course
when we played against him and then it's
in Pro bowls but uh yeah great obviously
can you can you know if you look at the
generations and the way it was
officiated the number of times you
passed you know it's changed now now can
you truly make a comparison
that you know Tom Brady and Joe Montana
or Dan Marino or John Elway like can you
put them all in the hopper and say yeah
you know we can or do you have to do it
generally uh you know in a generation by
generation
yeah I think it it becomes hard you know
it's the great thing about sports is is
those debates and being able to have
those conversations uh I I just think
that if if if your argument is based on
numbers
uh then then it's unfair because the the
numbers obviously are dramatically
different now because of the way that
the game is played but with that said I
don't think the numbers that we're
seeing from today's quarterback should
take away from anything that that the
quarterbacks are doing because we've got
some amazing players right now so yeah I
think in the context of of how you're
evaluating these guys it's hard to go
outside of each generation but yet uh we
all do it I I just think when you start
making the list of the top quarterbacks
of all times it seems like we forget
guys who played a really long time ago I
always say autogram should probably be
on that list yeah you know somewhere and
uh and yet those those type quarterbacks
tend to get forgotten he's Troy Aikman
Hall of Famer and uh he's joined us a
few times to talk about his beer eight
and uh first class product no hidden
agendas there big beer weekend I'm
assuming if you go to a barbecue you're
bringing the beer
uh yeah yes and I hope that for all
those people in Texas because that's
where we are eight beers you know is
only in Texas I'm hoping that everyone
is having a barbecue this weekend uh
we'll indulge a little bit uh with some
eight beer but yeah actually I've got
the uh the Patriot hat on today we've
got a patriot package for eight over the
next month uh goes towards the military
Warrior support Foundation to honor
those uh people who have served so it's
a good weekend for family and friends to
all get together but it's also a great
weekend to honor those who paid the
ultimate sacrifice
how much did you celebrate when you were
with the Cowboys
how much did I celebrate yeah I would
say party but then given some of your
teammates that might take on a different
connotation so so did did you enjoy
being the Cowboys quarterback
yeah how did you enjoy being the Cowboys
quarterback
oh well you know Memorial weekend since
we're since it's upon us uh I I used to
throw a
yeah you'd say a backyard
barbecue picnic it started as that
then it turned into uh where I was
renting out Bill bates's Ranch and uh it
was an all-day Affair so uh I I I
probably enjoyed it a little too much
from time to time and no cell phones
back then
thank God yeah
help me understand the kickoff where
we're going with this as an analyst
um what do you want well as a former
player like what what should we still
have with the kickoff
yeah I you know Dan I look at it from uh
from both perspectives because I
understand I I've seen where some
players and coaches aren't happy with
with the change in the kickoff rule uh
and if you're a special teams player
that's that's how you make your living
and that's how you make your uh your
that's how you earn your opportunity to
be on a team uh so when some of those
types of rules are put into effect it
affects you know your livelihood but you
know I I will say I also see it from
someone now who's been removed from the
game for close to 25 years that safety
is uh the top priority and for obvious
reasons and and the kickoff uh I'm not
in those meetings but it seems like each
year I'm hearing that the kickoff is
when most of the injuries are taking
place so uh I I applaud the league and
the owners and everyone who's involved
in trying to make the game safer but yet
I understand why there's some
frustration uh from the coaches and the
players that are involved with it how
would you take the response Mike
McCarthy had that we need to run the
ball more if you were still the
quarterback of the Cowboys
or your Dak Prescott and you hear your
head coach saying we need to run the
ball more
uh well we
I can't imagine that that would have
ever been said while I was playing
because we ran it more you know we were
already there with with Emmett Smith
um but
I don't know I I look at the teams
around the league and there's not a lot
of them but the the team that comes to
mind of course is San Francisco we see
it with Tennessee but they they haven't
enjoyed quite the same level of success
that we've seen from San Francisco but I
love that offense that Kyle Shanahan is
running and it reminds me a lot of the
Cowboys teams that I was a part of as
far as the the commitment to running the
ball uh and then the play action passing
off of that and we did skew heavily
towards the passing game and when you
have quarterbacks like Aaron Rodgers or
Patrick Mahomes and you know Josh Allen
and those type talented guys I get it
and then along with the rules but I do
believe that we're starting to kind of
bring the pendulum back towards the
middle and those teams that are running
the ball uh are having a lot of success
so uh in Dallas there there has been uh
they have thrown the ball a lot Kellen
Moore who's now with the Chargers he I
think did a really great job but I think
it was a little bit outside the box of
where McCarthy wanted to be so I'm not
I'm not surprised by it I don't think
it's a bad thing I but with all that
said
uh if to me if you had to choose between
one or the other that you're going to be
good at you better be good throwing the
football uh if you're going to win in
today's League how safe is Emmett
Smith's all-time rushing wrong
yeah I I I think it's pretty safe I
can't imagine I can't imagine in my
lifetime that I'll that I'll see anyone
really threaten that record the game the
game's gonna have to change uh
dramatically
um but you know now with with 17 games
if you're able to stay healthy you know
who knows uh if there becomes more of an
emphasis on throwing the ball but that's
the thing that that I always admired
about Emmett when you start talking
about numbers The Yards obviously are
impressive but what's most impressive to
me and what has always been most
impressive to me is a guy who had a
front row seat is in order to put up
those kinds of numbers two things have
to happen you have to you have to have
great years you have to play and have
great years but you have to but you have
to play you have to be on the field so
for me Emmett's greatness besides that
he played well was that he didn't miss
games I mean he was on the field I I bet
I can count on one hand the number of
time number of games that Evan Smith
missed in his career while he was with
the Cowboys and you know to me that in a
lot of ways when you start looking at
big numbers that guys have put up over
their career that's usually what stands
out the most is they just simply didn't
miss much time
I got Emmett missing five games in 13
years and there you yeah yeah there you
go and you know any and it was a
different League then too yeah running
backs don't get hit now but that's a lot
of punishment uh and for him to be able
to in fact we a lot of times Dan we
didn't even have a backup running back
to speak of and and in addition to that
Emma was a three down back you know so
he played on third Downs well and uh as
well and people don't realize just how
good of a blocker uh he was so uh just a
great great player and a great teammate
uh in every way you know when you go to
a game now and you hear a game
do you hear it differently than you
heard when you were playing the game
when you're actually getting hit or
you're really close by these hits now
you're watching people be hit I tell
people all the time if you get a chance
to watch a game from the sidelines you'd
never play football yeah you wouldn't
you wouldn't no I I remember my first
NFL game when I was standing on the
sidelines
don't put me in people go to jail for
this stuff
but did you yeah I was watching NFL
network uh just the other day and they
were they were showing some games from
back in the early 2000s or whatever it
was and it it was you got you I mean I
know it was different because my body
tells me the game was played differently
but yet until you go back and really
watch some of these games pretty amazing
what was allowed at one time
give me one tip for a rookie quarterback
these rookie quarterbacks
well I was given some advice uh when I
was coming into the league and I was
told hey you know it's a long year and
the leagues and the game's gotten longer
each you know with 17 games but uh thing
you know don't get too high when things
are going well and don't get too low
when when things are going poorly
because it is such a long it's a roller
coaster and in college when you're on a
good team as I was you know everything's
a good every week's a good week and you
have very few losses when you come from
some of these great programs and you're
going to go through a lot of Ebbs and
flows of a season and I thought that was
I thought that was really good advice
and I think the coaches that are able to
navigate that and and and maintain some
consistency I think they give their
teams the best chance too
and I whenever you talk to younger
players I always say you know what
they're on the other side and their job
is to hurt you their their job is to
take you out you don't have to be a
macho man like taking on contact there's
nothing wrong maybe that used to be I
don't know back in your day if you had
to be a tough guy but Lamar Jackson and
some of these other players it's okay to
get out of bounds did you feel like you
had to be a tough guy
well I I did but I think that I I think
that that came from uh being raised by
my father who pound for pound was the
toughest guy I knew so long before I
ever got to the NFL I I felt that that I
had to be a tough guy but then for a
quarterback that's really how you earn
the respect I think of your teammates uh
is playing through pain and not to
suggest that what you said because
coaches more than than now quite
honestly is they would tell you to get
to the ground and you would not take
unnecessary hits we now see quarterbacks
that that are taking what would be
deemed unnecessary hits and and offenses
that are geared towards the quarterback
running
um so that's I I didn't think I would
see that especially now with the amount
of money yeah the quarterback's always
been the highest paid guy but uh Lamar
Jackson you know as much as he runs I
know that they're maybe not going to on
the ball as much there this year with
the new offensive coordinator but uh
yeah that's certainly important to keep
these guys upright and the league knows
that they're the stars and they're
they're what sells the game before I let
you go what's that feeling like when you
know you're going to get hit
right in the mouth or in the sternum but
you have to hang in there to complete
the past uh I I never minded that I
never ever had a touchdown or or a
completion uh I I've got a number I got
a lot of scars on my chin here Dan from
uh from taking a lot of helmets
underneath the chin strap uh when I was
playing uh in order to try to you know
that was my game I I wasn't the the most
mobile guy so you know I think you know
guys like Tom Brady and Peyton Manning
would say the same thing but that was
that was the nature of what you had to
do and if you were unwilling to do it
you just were not going to be successful
and you got stitched up during games
oh yeah yeah about seven or eight
different times I almost got stitched up
as many times as I had concussions back
when I was when I was playing so it
didn't take much either I mean it got it
got uh
pretty caught up pretty good yeah you
can't tell makeup makeup will cover that
up on TV that's right you know that yeah
I mean I got it on without makeup you
should see this face you know
unrecognizable yeah yeah I look like
Terry Bradshaw
no that's not true that's me hey good
luck uh with the beer we always
appreciate talking to you and uh thanks
for joining us thank you Dan that's uh
T-Roy Aikman
eight committed to producing first class
product no hidden agendas authenticity
matters join team eight